وخلال كلمه لها في المنتدى اكدت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسلها فوندر لاين دعم
اوروبا الثابت لاوكرانيا مشيره الى ان
المفوضيه ستقدم دعما بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات
يورو لدعم قطاعي التعليم والصحه في
اوكرانيا وشدد فوندر لاين على ضروره
محاسبه روسيا على جرائمها وعلى انه لن
يكون هناك افلاتهم من العقاب في اوكرانيا
تقدم مزيدا من الاسلحه الاوكرانيا ونحن
نستضيف نحو اربعه ملايين اوكراني في مدننا
ومدرسنا وقد فرضنا العقوبات الاكثر سلامتا
على اقتصاد الروسي لن يتمكن الرسول من
الافلات من العقاب لن نتراجع عن دعمنا
الثابت لاوكرانيا عبر مساعدتها لاعاده
الكهرباء وتدفئه المياه وجهوده عاده
الاعمار
على ان المفوضيه ستقدم دعاما ماديا بقيمه
ثلاثه مديره وهذا الجزء الاول من حزمه
بقيمه ثمانيه عشر مليار يورو لعام 2023
وهو الدعم الاكبر بنسبه لدوله خارج
الاتحاد الاوروبيه